hi everyone I'm serene I am Jess and
today we're playing a horror game we are
we're playing layers of the air that's
right it's an early access game on Steam
developed by a team called Bluebird team
and it's running on the Unity engine and
I have to say it is pretty damn gorgeous
and yeah it's worth checking out so
let's get straight into it and show you
why this for our game is with your
attention scary times okay this really
really does look gorgeous so your paint
all right that's pretty much what I know
about this okay that's terrifying you
are a tormented awesome Ventus you start
off in this house which I assume is his
and then you sort of like oh can we
paint no you can't paint yes okay later
well where the painting is the relative
but you kind of go around the house
discovering that some really strange
things have taken place oh whoa um tapes
you can pick up things and look at them
you can see that they'd broken as well
so he's obviously not really happy with
his work oh my goodness he's very much
plainly part of this Oh what's a sec
tormented artists wow that didn't write
this that's that's some perfectionism um
and the holes I think stick of this game
is like it's sort of like his mind is
going a bit weird and like he's being
tortured by and say he's desired to
create the perfect piece of wow okay
that's really heavy oh god don't
just at over age this feels oh my this
feels a little amnesia while we stuck
where are we going where we going now
can we go out hey this is what I
discovered while playing the yesterday
that uh I'm not really sure what's
happening in the game because the house
that you're in keeps changing oh my gosh
that's that's kind of the worst this is
the kind of game that just makes you
want to leave like find the front door
and leave oh my gosh going in circles
and like there's a bit of a motif
there's like some metaphors around as
well but one of the recurring wants is
there's lots of alcohol bottles they're
broken and you can fiddle with a little
things like open covers and unloads and
doors it's just stuff to go to I thought
happened a lot to me while I was playing
actually if their stuff to find and
covered some things there is getting
goodies there are things that you have
to take up and look at and letting keys
you use some walk um you know Owen you
turn on candles would
Oh numbers for we need that yes we do
okay good oh good one oh sweet it helps
cut I Flav's is already pissed it
doesn't make it any less tensile scary
okay what do we get it up the top holds
back with thought alone oh my that's
really pretty have my needle what he
says was kind of stabbing their souls Oh
possession much yeah he might have
issues and the door appeared never
forgets ah that's creepy I don't like
and stuff changes oh well this time but
died that's right i do remember stuff
happening but the problem is since old
the house kind of loops and looks the
same I don't remember what order it
happened so you might even versus title
me a guy upside down it's a doll oh it's
a doll I totally cut that happen what
why do we fall can't believe in a can
long tunic oh my god it's like fully
dark I don't like this I'm going towards
the source of light because there's
another one god I thought that was no
don't even say it though this is killing
him I don't wanna be good is that it
goes what I guess Oh painting
this is awful tormented artist is not
cool tormented the game is he is Oh
opensuse fight secret door be her and
chill Oh what everything looks like a
people everything looks like people that
would suck people okay let's not full
through the hole in the ground again um
yes let's will do that and keep moving
Oh like even though the game does seem
to be confusing at times it kind of
always is able to nudge you forward even
though you mean like oh boy you feel
like yours oh what's that yes just like
I mean it's not that pose I want a guy
man all those lovely curves just right
it's creepy this guy's not all there I
mean it's obviously not all there but
really not all that mm yes and I'm not
really sure what the goal is other than
walk around and keep making things
happen well I guess you're unraveling
yeah narrative Emily's the mystery of
what happened between him yeah why was
it a house I mean that's just cool now i
did this war look who's gay looking in
the painting and they each turn around I
got me real good I'm sorry we don't
applied a piece of skin for some reason
oh we put the scale on here yes and I'm
like I right escape of course we did
sweet Jesus upon Judas my half of the
department store honey Thank You Ivan
know yet if it's all good Lily things
didn't go well no I would say things
didn't go all right let's keep talking
shall we let's forget to the Tarot okay
all right and this wall kind of has like
these notes that you phone picked up all
the way okay well we kind of good for us
it's that one but that's okay what
something tell me to do with a
prosthetic leg all right really sure if
you do I have a perfect like we don't
have any legs sore encoding because of
course all right we can do moving along
let's look at how preparing all right we
power through the fear Oh an elevator I
don't know let's take it there let's
hope it goes up and not down I better
goes down other they always go down
what's the worst that could happen
please up oh yeah the other direction
might go down grave we have company in
the house of things but that looks
really company how big is this house to
live in like a 3-up would be better oh
[ __ ] that's a Sox dude so this is like a
scary odd game on game yeah I thought
it'd be like painting stuff and be like
whoo disturbing our things were getting
real hope you guys signed up to he me
wins for the next ten this is that's
what you can Oh blip light the light oh
yeah i think really oh ok let's candy
look backwards all the door and no
didn't it did not--did it's alive why
would it hey calm down everything's fine
Oh a key oh god okay I don't like this
anxiety what that's right changing house
it's like an airport of the causes of
businesses she came yes
why did you stop that jewel was perfect
honey please just a lil longer at least
until I finish painting this way she
played the piano and he wasn't hot oh
don't make me beg [ __ ] the whole lot so
I think you can't move with cutscenes
right it's like amnesia right they slow
you down did that painting just change
it did didn't know homie but yeah I mean
like that I expect he however do without
the awesome graphics and creepy shadow
figures madness I feel like I keep
seeing things like the games missing
with my eyesight and make me see your
paintings keep changing I think yeah
it's really well look at melting melting
now I was gonna play tonsil dolls today
I'm here no this is too much okay my
threshold hey you how are you special
for today has been don't define oh
that's died
good what are you asking the sound of
crying dog alright so dog but I'm fire I
think we're gonna be chased cuz I feel
like we're gonna be chased I cannot be
undone I cannot be undone I don't know
her I don't know everything okay the
phone hello yes because maybe we say
Jaden one member pt Oh Oh Jerry Jareth
Kashi which hospital so though the
hospital I'm on my way does a fire in
his wife oh wow had to go to hospital
super groom it is very grim and also
remember that she was at some point with
child so it cannot be undone I bet equal
as a fire why can't go through an
invisible barrier has stopped me so oh
wow Oh better scary something let's keep
it all exciting and safe life let's keep
it safe I'm being boarded into my own
house
very nice I don't I don't want that um
well it's unfortunately pretty see how I
worry about when horror games get really
good graphics cuz that's when it's gonna
get scary that's when [ __ ] gets two
wheels all right what singing is not
happy about the state of the house why
its my house I'll do what I want it was
like that all along who knows maybe
we're just walking through the park nope
an internet presence of the future I'm a
hardware on this one I got a hot what's
going on Hank such an ab workout right
now no go away no no very good i like
that wheelchair out of nowhere the
subtle stuff that gets you this about
you who quiz that door word I said don't
know let's open each of these rules
individually be questioned and wake up
the key know about theirs are all closed
snore no cuz it wasn't bc didn't you see
him I'm gonna do it I didn't want to do
it Hey look at their little smile
lighting the candles just everything is
ok just gonna light that loss Kendall me
the bed now changing my name is changing
Silent Hill we're going to another
dimension big happy thought OMG can I
open the door yet nope no that's in here
one of these times that doors is gonna
bust open up yeah let's stand away from
it then there because my car I'm
everywhere it's okay let's just not be
near the scary thing oh the walls
changed again now that I can't I go out
here bro Oh paint i'm guessing i
followed the trail oh ok left all right
well this one goes to this painting
that's melty wasn't and the other day is
he is so and i use the cave ok so let's
see what this here looking nice and
light this way i can say these things i
don't like where the game stops to load
because it means loading something oh my
god that's so true you just met it this
way that all right like oh well this is
nice it's a the gramophone uh-huh yellow
yeah yeah yeah yeah do you want to play
it ok nothing on this oh we can roll its
hand ok let's let's roll it oh you're
right there's something it looks oh how
I roll I mean you rolled it you did roll
it I don't think it's gonna play but you
know that's fine we tried there's a
lovely bed and oh here we go Oh record
so we put the record ok oh nice one and
we play it you know how the function
aground friend no but we have this issue
before we all made up in a snag one of
it all right you mean the twisty of them
oh can we look ok so
invaded stumbling out of there laughing
everywhere I kind of wish we hadn't
noticed hey I exception Oh melty Oh the
room is nothing to do so a problem scary
holes beds melting another issue your
jaw and less exciting I guess I start
them guessing for a new house stars
don't think that's the same stuff the
tube in a vein sucked on my lucky then
well your tube in the jar it just kept
coming gratis them copper haunted me the
entire night either I learned the super
[ __ ] one
something's happening so gramophone
melted everything melted everything
melted everything melted oh my god make
it seem jumping all around stomping all
around something all around still work
that's good sounding everywhere let's
say we can leave a high def okay go away
it's on an open its unloading oh good
good good good good the grandma food has
a power to undo time Oh jar blood on me
now yay leaving oh the painting right
all right well it's good this is a good
place to to wrap up with a flesh
flamingos and blood on the painting but
what's happening for me Maja's form 000
form is emerging of the page oh whoa I
don't even know what that turned into
you but it's not cool yes I think my
good premise of the game is to go around
cooking these clues and hints until you
finish the painting oh ok cool and great
and then you're helping him out I guess
with the weird skin stuff and I'll see
one look these is you guys sure alright
that's super sweet well that's probably
a good little glimpse of the game thank
you for playing it so I didn't happen no
worries thank you yeah it wasn't layers
of fear you can check that out on Steam
early access if you're interested and
check out more on gays [ __ ] home thanks
for watching guys
you